the single biggest spike in one day 32
more coronavirus cases in England in
just 24 hours from Lancashire to London
and Carlisle to Manchester 29 of these
had travelled abroad but nobody knows
how the other three caught the virus
this is a health crisis that threatens
to grow into an economic one workers
forced to self isolate but fearful of
losing income some reassurance from the
Prime Minister's I can today announce
that the health secretary will bring
forward as part of our emergency
coronavirus legislation measures to
allow the payment of statutory sick pay
from the very first day you were sick
instead of four days under the current
rules will he guarantee that workers
right to sick pay from day one as he's
just indicated will apply on statutory
sick play will apply to all claimants
and those people that are not currently
eligible for statutory sick pay we are
very much aware of the issues faced by
the self-employed on those on on zero
hours contracts I should stress that
some of them will be entitled to
statutory sick pay others a great a
great many emergency legislation will
help to reinforce the government's
containment strategy it doesn't want
infected workers to spread the virus but
it doesn't really address the concerns
of say freelancers or self-employed
people who work from home they're the
sort of people that if this virus really
does take hold could be hit really hard
I remember getting a lesson
in Scotland First Minister Nicola
Sturgeon thanked NHS staff for their
response to the outbreak two new cases
here bringing the total to three and the
same in Northern Ireland two more cases
recorded here this new public health
campaign rolled out to make sure people
are getting the message the rise in
cases confirming the government's fears
with all epidemics what happens is they
start off very slowly and then they
gradually gather momentum and then
suddenly go up relatively fast now we
usually have a reasonable period of
warning before that happens and we are
modelling this out quite carefully from
the time that we get established
transmission in the UK if we get
established transmission in the UK which
I think at this time is more likely than
not then there will be a number of weeks
probably about six weeks before we start
to see a significant amount of
transmission this increase has prompted
a warning from doctors who fear they'll
be left exposed as this crisis develops
they have worries about their own
protection
in particular in general practice they
need to receive supplies of appropriate
masks and that is the same of course for
our junior doctors then our consultants
ask colleagues in emergency medicine
departments and anywhere on the
frontline the response to this outbreak
may well be entering its next phase as
the numbers leap containment may no
longer be viable we're not in the delay
phase yet but we are very close Ashish
Joshi Sky News